eh la presencia de la otan en Europa del
este representa un temor para Rusia y
bueno la adhesión la posible adhesión de
Ucrania a la alianza por sobre todas las
cosas modificaría muchísimo para Rusia
todo lo que es la geopolítica de la
región recordemos que en el año 2018
hubo una suerte de primer coqueteo no
para el ingreso de Ucrania a la otan
luego en el año 2014 parecieron como que
se intensificaron todos estos esfuerzos
porque ahí juega un rol fundamental todo
el conflicto en crimea no la anexión de
la Península de crimea quisiera
preguntarle Jesús agreda rudenco
entonces las consecuencias bueno las
estamos viendo por supuesto muchísimas
de este avance de la otan hacia el este
está justificada en la amenaza que
denuncia Rusia bueno Es una muy buena
pregunta y curiosamente entre todas las
justificaciones de Rusia para la
invasión tal vez la expansión de la otan
es la única que tiene sentido porque la
otra es la de nuevo la desgasificación
de un país por un por un presidente
judío lo otro es el caso de de de un
genocidio que se demostró que finalmente
no existe pero el caso de la otan es
bastante cierto o es bastante relevante
sobre todo porque históricamente Rusia
considera que efectivamente su seguridad
es muy muy muy vulnerable Rusia se
considera a sí mismo como un acto
vulnerable Y por esa misma razón ha
tratado de garantizar su seguridad
creando una especie de Estados colchonas
a su alrededor una especie de zonas de
influencia que evite llegar a sus
enemigos seguramente occidentales a
llegar hasta Rusia entonces vemos como
la misma cortina de hierro y este bloque
de estas democracias populares alrededor
de Rusia no es más sino una continuación
de esa política durante la Guerra Fría
Rusia intentó crear digamos este tipo de
bloques Pero cuando la unión soviética
desaparece y efectivamente la otan
empieza a expandirse es Claro que Rusia
se siente vulnerable porque por primera
vez en la historia no tiene esa
protección y siente que ante sus
fronteras efectivamente hay una amenaza
directa sin embargo Me parece que vale
la pena discutir sobre Hasta qué punto
al mismo de la otan Es realmente una
amenaza para Rusia o es la
interpretación que Rusia hace desde la
organización y de su expansión lo que
finalmente Pone pone a las dos partes en
choque personalmente creo que no es el
caso creo que desde desde el 91 la otan
ha evolucionado de manera muy
significativa haciendo que finalmente
primero Rusia desaparezca del discurso
mismo la otan como una amenaza y segundo
Que la otan empiece a responder a otro
tipo de necesidades que corresponden muy
específicamente a las necesidades de sus
miembros que no tienen nada que ver con
Rusia en muchos casos pero que Rusia
interpreta de manera equivocada me
parece y finalmente se mantiene en un
discurso propio de la Guerra Fría pero
que la realidad históricamente no
justificaba bueno y ahora quiero que
hagamos esta diferencia que ya habíamos
hablado antes entre Qué es ser un
miembro de la otan Y ser un país Aliado
que es lo que significa Ucrania y esto
también para darle paso a que hay un
artículo que es el cinco dentro de los
estatutos de la otan que dice que si
atacan a un país todos los países de la
alianza Van a responder en conjunto que
es un artículo que no cobija en
principio Ucrania precisamente por no
ser un país miembro y hay otra
diferencia bastante sutil en el lenguaje
que radica toda la diferencia en el
campo de batalla y es el concepto de
defensa y ataque Y esto es porque la
otan en dentro de sus principios dice
que puede defender a un país Aliado como
lo de Ucrania para evitar que se escale
el conflicto sin embargo dice la otan no
puede pasarse de la defensa al ataque
precisamente por ser un país Aliado y no
un país miembro y entre estos términos
de si por ejemplo los leopards 2 que
accedió a enviar a Alemania son una
defensa para evitar un mayor ataque que
es como lo que dice occidente o como lo
que dice Rusia esto ya es una ofensiva
directa cuál es esa diferenciación entre
los términos país miembro y país Aliado
y entre los términos defensa para evitar
el ataque y una ofensiva
digamos es un lenguaje muy sutil pero es
un lenguaje que marca la diferencia
entre una guerra o no entre una invasión
o no tal Como se muestra en el caso
Ucrania efectivamente la otan nace como
una organización de defensa colectiva
una organización que busca evitar o
disuadir la agresión de la Unión
soviética o en caso de que se dé ganar
una guerra es decir es un esfuerzo por
compartir recursos materiales
suficientemente fuertes como para que
nadie piense en atacar al país a los
países miembros que que estaba dirigido
directamente a la unión soviética por
supuesto y segundo tener los recursos
suficientes por si alguien decide atacar
algún país miembro tener la capacidad de
responder y ganar una guerra entre
términos militares Sin embargo a partir
del 91 efectivamente en la naturaleza
misma de la otan empieza a transformarse
y se pasa de un sistema de netamente de
defensa colectiva un sistema de
seguridad colectiva En otras palabras La
idea es empezar a identificar amenazas
para los países miembros que no son
exclusivamente una invasión militar
porque de nuevo la naturaleza misma de
la seguridad europea cambia
eso implica cambiar un poco los recursos
que necesito la otan y también redefinir
las prioridades de la otan entonces en
periodo de los noventas por ejemplo la
estabilidad regional y los conflictos
regionales se vuelven una prioridad por
la otan y cambia las necesidades de la
otan entonces la otan deja de ser de
alguna forma una institución o un órgano
muy estático para convertirse en un
órgano mucho más activo que finalmente
pueda participar en mecanismos de
estabilización política incluso Por qué
no de esterilización económica a nivel
regional
sin embargo eso no se puede lograr sin
tener aliados En otras palabras la otan
no puede por sí sola de nuevo
proyectarse e imponer su voluntad a los
demás sino que la otan necesita una
serie de aliados que participen en ese
tipo de mecanismos y sean clave en esta
estabilización regional ahí es cuando
aparece el concepto de aliados incluso
aparece este concepto digamos un acuerdo
para una alianza para la paz con los
estados exoviéticos donde se invita
incluso a Rusia a participar en esta
estabilización regional
sin embargo lo que vemos ahora es que
por puesto digamos a Rusia no tiene la
misma percepción y Rusia me parece de
nuevo volviendo lo que dije antes no ha
entendido ese cambio o esa
transformación la otan y sigue muy
estancada en la interpretación de la
Guerra Fría de la otan donde la otan
tiene una única función y es contener a
la unión soviética y eventualmente
contenida de Rusia creo que eso es un
error Rusia ha decidido que digamos su
seguridad lo va a tomar en sus propias
manos y sigue considerando que la otan
es la principal amenaza
desestabilización a nivel regional y
considera que efectivamente la
participación de Ucrania en en esa
organización es inaceptable Aunque por
otro lado hay que discutir Hasta qué
punto la participación de Ucrania en la
era real efectivamente en 2008 habían
algunas ideas pero la candidatura de
Ucrania nunca se había consolidado y era
Claro que incluso dentro de los mismos
países miembros de la otan no había una
unanimidad suficiente para aceptar a
Ucrania como estado y bajo esa lógica se
empieza a derrumbar un poco el argumento
de Putin de que efectivamente Ucrania ya
iba a ser parte de la otan era
Inevitable Y eso obligó a Rusia actuar
parece que ese no era el caso entonces
sumando dos elementos primero la
evolución de la otan como organismo que
pasa de ser una conexión de colectiva a
un sistema de seguridad colectiva sin
dejar de lado la parte de defensa por
supuesto una organización mucho más
activa Y sumado a eso Por supuesto la
idea de que Ucrania no iba a ser
realmente parte de la otan porque no
había una vía libre para el país podemos
afirmar que de nuevo Parece que la
argumentación de Rusia no es lo
suficientemente sólida como para
justificar su precio militar